I know we've kept it fairly positive and
upbeat but I'm just wondering is there
anything about the screenwriting process
that you hate what is it you know what
the process of just starting to write is
so challenging that I often come up with
the title first it's so backwards like I
don't know any screenwriter who they're
like like literally I've written a whole
screenplay from a title that inspired me
there's a title of the big empty a
friend of mine had a song called the big
empty and I was like that's a great
title for a script the big empty so I
literally wrote the big empty and
thought okay what's it gonna be about
and then I can't what no script for what
this was gonna be about so I think it's
just getting started I'm not someone who
does even even though my very first
successful screenplay was almost like
doing an outline it was like a stream of
consciousness treatment that I wrote and
then I realized after writing like 20 or
30 pages you should just write the
script you it's right here you should
just write the script but that's because
I have been marinating on it for so long
I could just do that but when it comes
to outlines which is a process that a
lot of script writers do and I'm still
trying to figure out how to do that I
really admire people who really know how
to outline and write their scripts from
there things are just a little bit more
organic for me but I can write like a
beginning a middle and an end but it's
usually about two or three pages of
stuff and a character breakdown I think
I just want to tangent what was your
actual question you so you're saying
that what you hate most is starting and
I'm thinking of how some people let's
say crewmates some are messy some are
neat do you think that there's just some
people that they get to the final
destination the same way but they just
have their own way of doing it where is
a teacher might look at it and say oh
that's bad that's wrong but it still
works out yeah
because it sounds like you don't like to
do the outlining but no but I feel I
often feel like if I had the I don't
even know what it is whatever it is that
that screenwriter has that makes them
sit down and discipline do the outline
yeah I think that my job might be a
little bit easier but I'm just saying
that because it seems like that works
really well it's like the studio way of
doing things too like TV you have to
give an outline and then you write the
script and oh I hope tell you a funny
story about that so I was in the the
Walt Disney Fellowship and I was in the
screenwriting version of it they don't
have the screenwriting arm anymore they
just had the TV yarn believe it or not
I've been trying to get them they get
the other one back but I wrote a
television script for them and at the
time it was the practice and my wife and
kids were the TV shows are on television
that I wanted to write for and they were
like okay so you have to pitch us your
story do an outline once we like the
story and then write the script right so
I pitched them the story they liked it
right and I was just like what's this
outline who I literally went I wrote the
script then I wrote the outline from the
scroll Wow
okay and then I gave me outline and
they're like this is great they made a
couple of tweaks for the outline so I
implemented the tweaks in the outline
and then I just went and implemented
between what the script was already done
it was just like a formality it was a
formality because that's the way that
they had to do it we had to do it that
way but it didn't make organic sense to
my process sure which is weird but you
know have you had people try to rein you
in and make you do it that way because
it sounds like it's it's still working
though that that's just what you I
definitely have and when I when I have
to I will but it's very uncomfortable I
feel like my organic process is just
different I understand why it works for
people I understand why they do it but
my body my brain just goes just right it
it's right here just right it what is
that like
we're wasting time right this grip some
people make their bed every morning
20 years of gone buy another one right
make it home again so do you find
yourself squirming to get out of
starting and then oh yeah finding it's
between house
spring spring cleaning and you know
reading books that I've been on the
shelf for years like I'm gonna read this
book I've been planning to read it for
10 years I'm gonna read it now and I'm
like really
really you need to be writing what are
you doing but um yeah you do everything
to get out of it and but once I'm in
there mm-hmm you know that's the crazy
part it's like once you're in there
you're in there just get in there but
that's easier said than done
but what do you think it is then that
that font when you fight like had enough
and you're like you know what I'm
procrastinating well how do you get
yourself in there well this is a saying
that I've said to my friends
procrastination with writing
procrastination is part of the process
and I truly believe that because I think
that just like birthing a baby you know
there's stuff going on while you're
procrastinating it's not like you're
just not doing anything your that's why
the writing process I think is so kind
of mystical in a way because there is
stuff happening if you go take a walk on
a beach or you're just hanging out or
whatever you are procrastinating but
you're not because there's two things
happening it's like a parallel thing
going on on the surface it looks like
you're doing this but your brain and
your body all this stuff is happening
that is gonna be useful for you when you
start writing it's just preparing you
gearing you up to write that's all it's
doing and I've realized that so I really
kind of you know I I lighten up on
myself about it because I believe that
procrastination is I call it
procrastination but procrastination in
the way that we're talking about is part
of the process
you